the growing of the brand you've done it
for so many other people like you don't
need me to tell you how to go from 3.5
million to 35 million I don't have 35
million I'm not going to tell you to do
that but you do know how to do it
because you've done it for other people
so what's the thing if you feel badly
asking what is the resistance I
definitely don't like asking for help if
I said to you make a list of people who
would be the absolute perfect people to
ask what would they say if you called
them right now I don't know what I'm
asking for Ah that's why you suck I love
that Laura that's it right there because
you are not clear on what the thing is
that you need like you know what you
have to offer you know who you would ask
to help you but you don't know how to
ask them you don't know what the
flywheel is like we all work together we
all rise together that take elevators to
the top that's the issue you haven't
been asking because you're not clear on
what the thing is that you want to ask
for and I think if you became clear on
that thing that's the win-win that helps
everybody it would be so easy for you to
ask you'd be doing it in your sleep you
know your publicist this is a friend of
mine we've done lots of these kind of
interviews and yet like I'm still
nervous not to the point where I'm gonna
say hey Laura we can't do this but still
nervous like I thought the internet is
down and Canada thing was it was BS you
were just having like a whole fee now I
know the truth now I know the truth
foreign
everybody welcome Laura gastner odding
to the program to tell me why I suck
this show is all about bringing on the
world's leading experts on different
areas and they coach me on areas that I
suck at to try to get better Laura
welcome aboard
Kevin I've got to say um there have been
a lot of conversations I've had with
people where I've wanted to tell them
why they sucked and I haven't been
allowed to so what a gift
so I came up with that idea because
often when you ask for feedback people
will tell you a couple things but not
like the real truth because they're
afraid of hurting your feelings I know
from watching your stuff you're not
afraid to kind of dive in and tell
people the truth so it's less of a
concern for you but it's still like I
want to get to the truth of how it can
get better and how it can improve you
know it's so funny that you say that
because they're there I had I had a
friend once who you know like me is a
keynote speaker and he I asked him for
feedback and the first thing he said was
um do you want feedback or do you want
praise because they're very different
things and most people who want feedback
want praise and I was like no no I want
feedback and then you proceeded to tell
me why I sucked
which was fundamentally like life
shifting for me in the way that I showed
up on stage and thank God that he
actually asked me that question because
otherwise I would have been like yeah
just give him your feedback and he would
have been like you were great and I
wouldn't have learned anything I try to
preempt it by saying hey tell me why I
suck and then people say well well you
don't suck but and then they tell you
you know kind of the honest truth so uh
anyway I'm looking forward to learning
how I suck and how I can improve you've
got this awesome new book out called
Wonder hell yes and my my quick summary
would be
so many people know that they're capable
of more they have this untapped
potential they see a vision for
themselves of what they could become
and then they struggle with the reality
of where they are at and then all the
self-doubts and insecurities come in
like maybe I can't do that I don't know
if I'm capable who am I to think I can
do this thing and just kind of internal
battle that is wonderful and also
hellish how is that as a summary
yeah I think that's perfect I actually
I'm in New York right now it's why I'm
in a hotel room uh so as you can see
behind me uh and I was on Good Morning
America this morning and uh Robin
Roberts we did this whole thing where
you could like see the different images
of who you are at these different
moments in your life and the but I think
so much of the problem is that we all
know that there's more inside of us but
we either don't believe it or if we
believe it we don't know how to get
there and then we have these internal
voices that tell us like you're an
imposter you shouldn't do it you don't
deserve to who am I to believe this and
then we have all those external voices
that the people are like are you really
sure you should do that are you sure
that's you know are you sure that's not
too scary right like you have all those
people who have all these opinions so
yeah I mean I think that's a great
summary and I'm I'm excited to dive in
because you wouldn't be asking the
question tell me why I suck if you
didn't know that there was more there
and you didn't want to figure out a way
to get there
um that's true that's a great start
so if I look at where I'm at now I've
got the channel has been growing it's
awesome we've had some of the biggest
names on the channel we have three and a
half million subscribers wow I want to
get the 35. he's like how do I 10x this
thing I don't know why I just blow it
out of the water and I have some days
where I wake up it's like it's totally
possible like 35 million subscribers
of course 35 million people you know in
America let alone the world need this
uh it's solving a big problem and then
there's other days was like yeah but
nobody's even come close to that in
education and kind of thought leadership
you take the top five channels in
industry and they don't even add up to
35 like who am I to go off and do this
thing I don't really have a lot of
negative voices around me I think if
anything it'd be more encouraging like
of course you can go off and do that but
it's more the internals like yeah but I
don't know I don't know how I get stuck
in the how land often like well how do I
do that like nobody's done that before
and it's that I'm living in wonder hell
right now you know it's like this is
something that should be achievable and
possible and yet you know I'm making
progress but not where I want to be I
have a lot of questions to ask you
before I tell you anything right I mean
I think I think anybody who jumps in and
just tells you before asking that you
shouldn't be listening to I mean that's
just my that's my that's the first thing
I'll tell you right that's my personal
opinion um so I guess look I mean you
definitely get Wonder hell like you go
to your website and the first thing you
see is this beautiful graphic about like
who you've been and who you're becoming
and I mean the person in the middle
that's Wonder hell right there so that's
always who you are Wonder Health that's
based on who you were and who you're
beginning you're coming you're becoming
so the first question I would ask you is
why why do you want 35 million so like
what's the what's the reason behind it
it's less about a number and more just
about the the feeling like I could have
a bigger impact I have the the words of
my mom I guess resonate which is if you
have the ability you have the
responsibility and so just I I can and I
want to serve so why not and it's less
about hitting like 35 isn't some magical
number it's it just represents having a
much bigger impact
um and feeling like I'm serving on a on
a bigger level so is 35 million the
right goal or is the right goal uh a
certain uh lever or set of levers that
would allow you to have impact with the
communities that you want like how much
of the 35 million is just to like crush
it 10x it like vanity metric because
that you just set that as a number and
how much of it like is 35 million the
number that gets you
fly will affect or gets you impact in
the way that you're defining it because
it seems kind of random to me I know no
it really is just like 10 10x what we're
at right now it's really just an
exercise in
trying to find a different way of
thinking
so that what got me here won't get me
there and so like what else to that
explosive explosive growth instead of
just the the incremental uh 35 doesn't
mean anything personally you don't get
some kind of award uh in terms of
opening doors and stuff like the channel
is already big enough to open up doors
and have conversations with almost
whoever I want to have on the channel
it's just more about how else I wanna I
wanna hit more people I want to serve
more people like people I want to spread
the message I believe and we're we're
the one there is like it's so possible
and people need this so much and like
how do I make that happen what is it
that people need that you are bringing
to them what is the problem that you
were solving and for who yeah I think
the biggest problem Humanity faces is a
lack of belief
I think in themselves themselves yeah
like I think whatever cancer should have
been solved a decade ago but the woman
who would have solved cancer as a
manager at KPMG doing a job because she
never believed in herself enough right
that's my like we solve solve
self-belief you solve every other
problem in the world I have a bias
towards entrepreneurs because that's who
I love helping the most so that would be
like helping entrepreneurs believe
themselves more not that you know
teachers in government and whoever else
can't do it I know your background is
like corporate stuff as well it's like
great corporations have a huge role to
play I just default to entrepreneurs but
the problem I'm trying to solve is
helping people believe in themselves
more I think the way to do that is
content at scale people get to learn
from you today and learn to have more
self-belief even though like one-on-one
time with you would be insanely
expensive but my journey hopefully they
can learn a little bit as well through
this session so that's what I'm trying
to solve and for who okay so you're
obviously very clever because through
the creation of to tell me why I suck
you basically figured out a way to get
like the most expensive coaches in the
world to coach you for an hour for free
which is by the way brilliant like as
soon as my publicist told me that that
was your plan I was like that is so
freaking smart I see your need for 35
million but I think it's kind of BS like
I don't think you need 35 million
because as you said you're already
opening doors you're already getting
whatever guests you want like you don't
need that number the 3.5 is impressive
enough right it's like I did Good
Morning America today do I need to do
like Today show tomorrow or what it
doesn't matter like Good Morning America
is like it opens the door like I don't
need to do it so like if you already
have the thing if you already have the
number then the question is do you just
need like a billion people from you know
India to sign up and subscribe like that
doesn't get you what you want so what
does who would be the people like if I
said to you fine you can't have 35
million you're only going to get five
I'm giving you 5 million
who are the other 1.5 who would help you
make the biggest impact in the people
whose lives you want to change why
aren't you going for those 1.5 instead
of another random you know
32.5
or 31.5 sorry I make my living with
words
I wasn't I wasn't caught up on the
number I think I don't have the I don't
have the clear how you know like I get
stuck on so you're saying okay go after
the influential people but if I had to
pick one no I'm not saying the how I'm
saying the who are you clear on The Who
uh well the who would be kind of
entrepreneurs around the world if I had
to only pick one and a half then I would
I would focus on the entrepreneurs who
could then go influence the other
entrepreneurs okay
so why aren't you doing that
um because if what you care about is
impact which is what you say you care
about first and foremost then you would
be going after the entrepreneurs who can
influence other entrepreneurs rather
than this vanity metric number
yeah
so
I do that in this I do that on a only
like super high level but not at the
next level so
a lot of the big name people have come
on my show I've helped them with their
like you should have a YouTube channel I
mean I know you do but it's like be like
Laura like we need to get your I don't
really have a YouTube channel I have
someone wrote right where I slap video
I'll like stick the GMA video on there
while I'll do absolutely Jack with it so
yeah so I have like my content on the
channel and like summarizing all these
lessons and then I'll help I'll help
people like you it's like okay Laura
you're such a genius like how do we get
your message out to the world like
people on YouTube need you they're going
there and searching and finding like BS
stop they need you right and so in your
message getting out to the world that
also helps me get my my said message I
believe out to the world
um and then I also train up and coming
thought leaders
on the skills to be able to record a
message and get that out to the world so
I'm I'm doing those things but not in a
the way you asked it was a very
strategic way I wasn't strategic about
it I was just doing it out of like I
just get I just care it's like Laura we
need we need Laura in the world not like
that helps me with my thing and how I'm
gonna hit my number right and that's
awesome right if you're like I want to
work with just specifically a handful of
high-level people to help getting them
get their message in the world and by
getting them getting their message in
the world that helps other people grow
fine amazing like I spent 20 years in
executive Search I was the CEO and the
founder of my executive Search firm but
I never really considered myself like a
CEO like it's sort of weird I was like
an accidental entrepreneur but I never
wanted to run anything I I'm like the
quintessential Chief of Staff type me
while I make my living like on TV and
you know on stage right now so I have
like a super weird job but I always
thought like I could either go and run
like all of my all of my searches were
in the non-profit Arena universities
foundations advocacy organizations
socially response corporations and I
thought okay either I can go and I can
run a non-profit and help a certain
segment of the population on a certain
issue in a certain Geographic zone or I
could use my talent my network my
knowledge to place a thousand different
Executives across
you know organizations that are weaving
the Civic fabric of our world over the
course of 20 years I could place the
first ever gay head of the ACLU the
first ever you know blackhead of you
know the hospital system in Connecticut
like I could place women in rooms that
used to all just be like this gendered
straight white males right like I could
I could make change at this level where
I was creating huge amounts of Ripple
impact
I'd love that I absolutely loved that I
I was so fulfilled by that that's what
you're doing when you're helping these
individual people but that didn't do
anything for my brand right I mean it
did great things because we got lots of
search and like our company grew 100
every year year over year my mission was
to create as much impact as I possibly
could so I did that by using the lever
of talent if your mission is to create
as much impact as you can it may be that
creating Evan Carmichael famous
superstar maybe that's not the goal
maybe the goal is how do I find 10
people who are already doing really well
and help them do you know they're doing
good let me help them do great let me
help these 10 people 10x and then all of
a sudden you've got this huge amount of
impact no shame right like if what
you're saying is I actually want to be
Evan Carmichael Superstar great awesome
let's do that but I think when you say I
want to create a lot of impact I just
don't necessarily believe that 35
million is the way to create impact
unless it's like 35 of the right million
then we get to this sort of strategic
question about how do you go out you
find the people but I want to unpack the
the question of like what does impact
really mean and what do you want to do
and how much of your own ego do you want
because again like no no shade like as I
said like I you know started a talk by
showing off about being a Good Morning
America like I'm all about the like
you can be a superstar cool like let's
do that if that's what you want yeah so
this is great so uh yeah 35 in itself I
could go buy a bunch of fake subscribers
from whatever country like you're right
so that's it has to be kind of the right
way so what is the right way it's not I
guess laid out is more of a heart or gut
question like that doesn't feel you know
authentic somebody asked me
I was telling me the story about that
there was a CEO Whisperer guy who kept
he was the guy behind Steve Jobs and a
whole bunch of other guys and he like
really helped him
um and said okay well what did he
like what did he end up building there
he's like oh nothing he just that was it
that's all he was he was like the CEO
whisper it just feels like it's not
enough I don't know maybe that's another
Wonder hell that I'm I'm diving into
it's like that doesn't feel like
that's that's the fullest expression of
what I could be able to create I
actually struggled doing shows like
interviews I was nervous as anything I
didn't know much about you before this
I'm like watching YouTube channel and
then like oh my God what's Laura going
to say to me you know you know Tony
Robbins has been on like four times I'd
rather have him on that's not less
nerve-wracking to talk to Tony a fifth
time than to have you come on because I
didn't know you yet and so like
naturally introverted and shy and the
whole point of this show was not even
just to do a normal interview show but
go like behind the curtains of hey
here's what I struggle with here's where
I suck and and hopefully in that
learning other people who are
introverted and shy and are here are
like they have the same warts as me they
have hope and I think like that is
something that is missing and that can
be a gift or contribution to the world
Beyond just hey I'm gonna help Laura and
Tony and whoever else build their
message out I mean I've so many
questions I want to know what why Tony
told you you suck because that would be
fascinating
um but I don't think you were doing that
the show in that way yet I've never met
him I don't know him I've I've never
been able to like get through his people
to like send him a book so you know we
can talk about that at some point I am a
raging introvert I'm a raging introvert
like there is nothing that I would
rather do than like sit in my living
room write my books and snuggle my dogs
and never leave my house like I and and
I make my living doing the thing that I
do and um this morning
um my my uh my niece who lives in New
York City came to Good Morning America
with me and she watched and like
producers kept coming in to like you
know check on me and like do the hair
and makeup and all this stuff and they
come in I'd be like hi it's great to see
you and I was like all up and then as
soon as they left it was like ah and I
just like sank back down and my niece
was like it is amazing how quickly you
turn it on and you turn it off and I was
like unlike an extrovert tourist right
like I hate it I can't do it but like I
can I can do it when I have to and then
I like have to sink back down and so the
first thing I'll say is like there is
absolutely a place in this world for
extroverts to do this and I'm so glad
that you're doing what you're doing and
you're Paving the way and you're telling
your story because I didn't believe it
like the first time I was asked to do a
talk I was like no freaking way I don't
want to that's terrifying I don't want
to do it um so I think it's really good
that you're doing it and I find you know
the bigger question of how do I go from
3.5 to 35
my following
has grown so much once I started talking
about the vulnerabilities and the
difficulties and the introversion and
all of them because I think that's so
much more relatable the second thing
I'll say is that last night on the plane
down I also brought my son with me and
um he's 18 and on the way down he was
like so why are you like you've done GMA
like three times like what does a fourth
time get you like what does it matter
and I'm like you know it just like the
more platform you have the more
followers you have the more leverage the
more influence you have and at the end
of the day I just want to be able to go
on Instagram and be like it's time to
vote people go vote or like here's this
thing I'm struggling with maybe you are
too you're awesome and you can do it
like the only reason I want a platform
is to be able to like move people in a
certain way at a certain time in a way
that matters and so if I were you I
would probably spend some time thinking
about who are the most influential
people who are you know influencing the
people who I want to influence right
like who are those people how do I get
them to uh partner with me to show up
for me to share about my stuff in a way
that will resonate with their people
like who are the right people and what's
the content that I have that makes sense
for them
but also Evan I don't know that I'm
telling you anything you don't already
know because you do this for other
people so the question really becomes
why are you not doing like why aren't
you doing it for yourself
doing what for myself
the growing of the brand you've done it
for so many other people
like you don't need me to tell you how
to go from 3.5 million to 35 million I
want 35 million I'm not going to tell
you to do that but you do know how to do
it because you've done it for other
people yeah yeah well I I need help
managing the Wonder hell you know yeah
so what's the thing is it like uh do you
feel badly asking is it like are you are
you uncertain like you said you don't
have imposter syndrome so like what
what's what is the the resistance did I
say it I I don't have impulse Ascension
I don't know maybe maybe I do
um I thought you said in the beginning
but I might have misunderstood that uh I
I definitely don't like asking for help
so that definitely is there I've come
more you know even your words about the
vulnerability and relatability it's like
it's I've become more
accepting of the fact that people want
to learn my story at the beginning I was
like why do you care about me like I'm
doing a profile of
of whoever these people are amazing you
know I've done some stuff but it's not
as big as them like why I learned from
me but in the pulling back of the the
curtain on a lot of these episodes
people connect and they like it it's
like okay like that is actually more
connection than what I learned from Elon
Musk or whatever at least for the right
person so I definitely need to lean in
more on my own vulnerability and
relatability to use your words which is
great which also created like this show
format because we could have had a great
discussion around Wonder hell and who
you've helped and who's this for and all
that and not make it personal but I make
it personal I mean this forces me to be
vulnerable and I don't know what you're
going to ask and where it's going to go
yeah and I think it actually is a
superpower because most people aren't
willing to be
coached you know live and open and I
don't mind it yeah and I was like unless
I'm not I'm not going to throw someone
in my family under the bus I don't know
what questions you know somebody might
ask but apart from that I'm open to
um feedback because it helps me and
hopefully helps other people but it's
just the idea that somebody could
somebody who's like me could watch you
and learn from this back and forth and
they could learn and make their lives a
little bit better maybe get out of the
one the hell that they're in because
they relate to it so I could definitely
do more work on my
my storytelling and vulnerability and
relatability it's it's um it's on the
list but maybe it's moving higher on the
list after talking to you yeah okay so I
heard two things in there the first one
was that you don't like asking for help
uh and the second one was why do they
want to listen to me somebody else has
done more stuff okay so
um let's tackle the let's tackle the the
the second one first and help to remind
me of the first one because I smoked a
lot of pot in college so I probably
won't remember it but uh we'll come back
to it so uh the second one somebody's
done more than me why do you want to
learn from me if I have never run a mile
in my life
and somebody walks in they're like I'm
an ultra marathon runner let me tell you
how I run I'm not going to learn
anything from them I'm gonna be inspired
by them right I'm gonna be like that's
amazing
that's amazing she's so smart that's so
incredible but I'm not going to be
motivated by them right the difference
between inspiration and motivation it's
Inspirations like wow that's so exciting
I feel so uplifted motivation motive I
want to move I'm going to move and I'm
going to do something with the knowledge
that I just got I'm not going to learn
anything from an ultra 100 mile like
deadville Valley Runner I'm just not I'm
gonna want to I think it's cool but I'm
not gonna learn anything but if you come
in and you tell me here's how I went
from running one mile training my first
5k to my 10K let me tell you about what
that's like and I'm like okay that's
relatable this person is in shooting
distance of like who I want to become so
there's lessons I can learn and I can
relate to it so I I I think you know so
many times people talk about like he
came up with this idea in his garage and
now he's a billionaire and they never
tell you about the messy middle and I
think if all we do is hear the stories
of the billionaires and we don't hear
about the steps in the middle I think
this does a disservice like I can own
all these podcasts because you know I'm
doing this whole media push around the
new book and everyone's like that's
amazing okay you've got such a great
career tell us how you have been so
successful and I'm like well I can tell
you the story one of two ways I can
either tell you the story as if it was
perfect and planned and thoughtful and
intentional or I could tell you the
truth which one do you want and I think
all too often we get the like BS let me
tell you the polished story so I I think
it is it is such a gift this is the
first gift we'll talk about such a gift
that you are giving people to show them
the in-between step the other part of
that I will say is when I first started
speaking I sat down with Allison Levine
Nelson Levine is the uh she captained
the first all women's expedition of
Everest right all American women's
expedition of everything badass badass
and she saw me speak and she came up to
me afterwards she's like you need to be
repped by a bureau you're amazing you're
great you need to be rep by Bureau and I
was like Allison I didn't climb Everest
no Bureau is going to want to rep me and
she looks at me and she goes well when I
first walked into Bureau they said oh
you climbed Everest cool did you saw off
your arm in order to get home safe
because we already got that guy right so
somebody's always going to have
something else somebody's always gonna
have something more is Allison Levine
not one of the most inspirational humans
on the planet I mean she's amazing the
woman makes a bajillion dollars a year
speaking she's been speaking on the same
story for 10 years because everybody
wants to hear it so like I think
don't steal away the gift from people
from showing them the middle step okay
the second piece is I hate asking for
help too in fact I literally sent out an
email last week to ask people to
pre-order the book and I was like the
subject line was I hate to ask but right
I hate it I hate it there's nothing it's
like I get like organ failure rejection
every time I have to ask anybody for
help for anything like it is just
awful it is awful and I mean like I am
strong and I'm proud and I'm a competent
human and I never want to ask for help I
literally in 2021 almost didn't make it
to 2022 I was so ill and I didn't ask
anybody for help and when I sent out an
email about it a year later telling the
whole story so many of my very closest
friends were like I had no idea I feel
so badly I'm like of course you didn't
know because I didn't tell you like I
hid away thanks to the pandemic nobody
got to see me and I just that's how much
I hate asking for help so I see you and
I honor that in you but let me ask you
this when was the last time you helped
somebody with something and how did you
feel when you helped them oh yeah no
great I mean probably today with my wife
you know it's like yes
you felt amazing so that's the second
gift that you're stealing away from
somebody to allow them to feel as good
as you felt helping your wife
so Evan why are you stealing all of our
gifts give us our gifts we want our
gifts yeah so this is this is maybe my
special version of Wonder hell and maybe
other people can connect to it too it's
the logic versus the emotion right like
logically that all makes sense and I
tell myself that too and like that's
honestly the thing that gets me over the
The Edge because otherwise I wouldn't do
it
the emotion of the fear is still there
so like I made a I made an Instagram
today uh I didn't mention your name but
basically talking about this
conversation saying I've got a
conversation coming up today and I'm I'm
nervous through the conversation and
logically it doesn't make sense like
I've I've had Tony on four times and
yeah I talked to bigger deals than me
yeah Matthew McConaughey and like all
these people and Laura has a great
message it's like it's not like you're
gonna come on and talk to me about
I don't know something I have no idea
about like this is exactly in the
Wheelhouse of what I do this all the
time it's in my wheelhouse she wants to
serve you know your publicist as a
friend of mine we've done lots of these
kind of interviews and yet like I'm
still I'm still nervous not to the point
where I'm gonna say hey Laura like we
can't do this but still nervous and so
it's like like the internet is down and
Canada thing was a was BS you were just
having like a whole feet that was
happening
to four and then rescheduled it now I
know the truth now I know the truth
yeah throughout all of Canada yes
so so my my way through was I went for a
walk
and they're now just missing the
connections like I wanted to connect not
just with like written word but like
your face your voice and so in watching
your YouTube videos like okay like she's
I get her you know like I I know kind of
where she's gonna go I I just feel
connected like you're my friend even
though we haven't talked yet that gave
me uh more peace or more courage or more
whatever like more at ease I guess
um but logically I fight with myself all
the time on the logic side of things
it's like yes this is something that you
can totally do and I'll I'll often lead
into either service like why am I doing
this well it's because Laura's got a
really important message that can help
my audience or it'll lean into more
courage or strength is like you do
difficult things come on like you do you
want to be the guy who didn't want to
talk to Laura you know it's like so one
of those I'll usually like it's the hug
or the push and use logic reasoning so
yes yes I hear what you're saying and
yes I
um I when I can catch it consciously use
those things and I still feel like
unconsciously or subconsciously the fear
is still there and like how to that
maybe that's my special kind of Wonder
hell so when I ran my executive Search
firm I I came to a realization that you
can maximize as an entrepreneur on three
things you can maximize on profit you
can maximize on personal freedom and
flexibility or you can maximize on
impact and I think I would probably say
that you can maximize on two of the
three at any given time so like you
can't pick two or the three on a Tuesday
and two other ones on a on a Wednesday
but like for like a season right for
like this year we're gonna maximize on
whatever it is and I cared very much
about impact and I had you know the 18
year old I told you about was my second
I had a 20 I have a 20 year old an 18
year old so I had a six week old baby
and I was working in you know Mission
driven organization so I cared about
impact and I cared about personal
freedom flexibility and I decided that
if I maximized on impact and personal
freedom and flexibility that the profits
would come and Evan I'll tell you we
grew 100 every year year over year I
ended up selling that firm for more than
I would ever have made if I stayed at
you know the regular big firm that I was
at when it came time to sell the firm I
we did a valuation and my business
partner was like oh I don't know we
don't have that kind of cash we can't
pay you we're not going to pay you that
we might as well shut the firm down and
start a new firm and everything I've
ever created in my life as an
entrepreneur still exists I'm very very
proud of that everything I've ever
created still exists I build
institutions not Cathedrals right
institutions not Cathedrals and I think
that that's a very important lesson as
an entrepreneur and I got my panties in
a bunch I was so upset about the fact
that she was like we're not going to pay
you we'll just shut the firm down and I
was like what are you talking about like
I spent years building this firm not
making any money so that I could build
this thing that I'm going to sell to you
and welcome like Merry Christmas right
like you have the sperm that's going to
be all yours and my husband came in one
day and he said you know you never ran
the firm for maximum profitability why
are you trying to sell it for maximum
profitability
and I was like oh you're right
eventually we came to a deal where I
sold for the firm for a dollar
plus a percentage of revenue for the
following five years
right so as long as they showed a dollar
of profit I got a percentage of Revenue
I ended up making more money on the sale
in the end after those five years than I
would have if she would have just paid
me out a straight valuation because at
the end of the day I decided I want to
run this as you know I want to sell this
in the same way Maximum Impact maximum
Freedom flexibility profits will follow
and so I listened to what you're saying
and I it sounds to me like you're you're
your ego is getting a little wrapped up
in this right like 35 million is is it
seems like a good 10x number that feels
like legit to my you know like chest
thumping entrepreneur friends the ego of
I don't want to ask people for help
because I I either I feel
um like I'd be a burden or I don't want
them to think I needed or like whatever
the stuff is that we want to get into
whatever the stuff is that's behind it
if I said to you
make a list of five people
10 people 50 people whatever you want
make a list of people who would be the
absolute perfect people to ask you to do
whatever the thing is you need them to
do and you know that they will 100 say
yes and thank you
for asking them to help you who would be
on that list
can you name a few people who would be
on that list I default go to people in
my industry so like okay I could go to
Tony we can go to Gary we can go to Tom
we can go to Mel and go to Alex or swap
okay what would what would they what
would they say if you called them right
now what do you think do you think
they'd say absolutely yes I don't know
what I'm asking for
Ah that's why you suck let's go Laura
that's it right there because you are
not clear on what the thing is that you
need like you know what you have to
offer you know who you would ask to help
you but you don't know how to ask them
you don't know what the flywheel thing
is where it's like we all work together
we all rise together the Ella we take
elevators to the top that's that's the
issue you haven't been asking because
you're not clear on what the thing is
that you want to ask for and I think if
you became clear on that thing that's
the win-win that helps everybody it
would be so easy for you to ask you'd be
doing in your sleep good so how do we
figure out what you're going to ask for
well I don't know I'm stuck on the how
well I mean you're in New York say take
Gary Right Gary vaynerchuk right okay so
yeah I mean I've known Gary for years
we've collaborated a whole bunch on
different things uh I don't know what I
asked him I mean like
and the default things that come to mind
seem too small and not like I'm gonna
ask him to share one of my videos to
share a channel like it just seems to no
small small potatoes yeah so what do I
Ask Gary for I don't know the biggest
asset I probably have in my business is
is untapped Goodwill with all the people
that I've helped when my last book came
out Limitless I debuted it as number two
on the Washington Post bestseller list I
was on today's show Good Morning America
all over the everywhere and um
how big do you think my mailing list how
do you think my following was in order
to do that as a first time author
a hundred thousand
lower
ten thousand
one thousand let's just keep minus 10x
in it
it's a trick question oh zero I didn't
have a mailing list I didn't even have a
mailing list my publicist calls me up
and she's like okay we gotta know like
how did you do that we have never seen a
ground game like yours before how did
you do it and I said because she's like
we want to tell all of our other authors
to do and I'm like I don't know I spent
the last 40 years showing up for people
and when I asked when I finally you know
grew a pair and asked people to help
they showed up back for me so you have
all of this Goodwill like there are so
many people in my life like even when
when Wonder Hall came out I posted
something last week and I was like if I
have ever in your life done anything
that has even remotely made your life a
little bit better if I've helped you in
any way if I ever saw you in a moment
where you were struggling if you were
having a hard time if you were you know
suffering would you do me this one favor
would you pre-order the book
likes and shares and purchases and all
of it like people were like thank you
like you've done so much for me thank
you for giving me a chance to just do
this one little thing and not only that
people were apologizing to me I'm so
sorry that all I'm doing is this one
little thing
untapped Goodwill is like gold
most people don't have the people to ask
most people don't have the good meal
most people show up every single day
with their hand out
and that's it right I mean there are
plenty of people in my network who have
not posted about my book who have not
sent me texts of nothing and I'm like
why are they being so quiet what's up
how interesting right like I'm not a
petty person but I will remember that
when their books come out right and they
send me the same text and they're like
would you post my book and I'm like yeah
I'll get to that next week
happy to do it but I'm not falling all
over myself now right I had people who
reached out to me and said look I know
you're on my show and your first book
came out and now you're this big F you
know big effing deal I know I'm you're
you're I'm you're too big for my show
now but I just want to tell you like
it's awesome and I Think You're great
and I was like when can we schedule the
show like you were there for me I will
always like that little show that has 75
people that listen to every single week
I will do that show every single time I
put a book up for the rest of my life
because that person took a chance on me
so there are people who you have helped
in your life who owe you
so very much that even if you ask for
like a big huge thing it's still going
to feel small so here's what I would say
I don't think you need to do one ask I
would give them three things give them
three options a big a medium and a small
and then they can say you know this is
not a great time I'm crushing on my own
deadline I'll do the one small thing
like you give them something to say yes
to because they don't want to have to
say no so you give them something to say
yes to and then they say yes or you ask
them for the big thing my guess is that
they'll probably always do the middle
but I would dream really big I mean
maybe you put together an event and you
have like a handful of these people who
are there and you sell a bunch of
tickets and they get money from being
there but what you get is all the email
addresses all the subscribers right like
you get all of their following
like you've seen everything like I'm not
going to give you tips and strategies
about how to grow your following I don't
know how to do that I would hire you to
help me do that like that's not my thing
I think where you're stuck is that
you're feeling shy about asking for the
thing that all these people would love
to give you
like if you were your own client what
would you tell yourself to do that's the
next one they're hell
just listen to our own advice and by the
way guys we keep saying Wonder hell
because that's Laura's new book and
we'll link that in the description below
just quick quick plug for the book as
well here let me ask you you know I have
all these connections right like I've
got my the book has been blurred by mail
by Amy Cuddy by Jonathan Fields like
I've great connections Robin Roberts
like told me she loved me on national TV
in front of four million people today
right like I have the same thing you why
don't you tell me what should I do
how do I 10x my following
create consistent content with bold
powerful opinions
you know and looking at your stuff
I had never seen your channel before
and and some of the videos are set to
kids so we gotta we gotta fix that
because your stuff is not meant it
limits the reach and everything but but
there's like so of course a lot so much
power in what like you
create maybe because it's my own like I
don't take a lot of bold stances on
things at least historically maybe it's
my canadian-ness or whatever but like if
you are opinionated
and you're willing to share that opinion
into a microphone and a video camera and
put it up and do that consistently like
you will grow
yeah so that's something that you would
not do because you're Canadian
uh a Canadian is my nice like fallback
option that makes people laugh to say oh
you're Canadian I know I'm not gonna let
you get away with that excuse I I know I
love a lot of Canadians and I'm not
gonna I'm not I'm
not no that's fine no that's fine that's
why we're here I'm on the I'm on the hot
seat
um I'm not going to tell you why you're
Canadian I'm gonna tell you why you suck
damn that's great yeah
those things are not synonymous
it's probably all connected somewhere
honestly I will usually see both sides
of things instead of laying in on one on
on most things
um I don't like the the vitriol and
negativity and like I want to spread
hope and positivity and believe and and
not the
not the stuff that pisses people off
right I mean when I don't get on stage
and say like we should kill all the
unborn babies like I don't I don't talk
about that stuff like I'm pretty
opinionated but it's not about like
third real political things I mean it's
a skill to work on or I need to do
therapy or keep doing this show and you
know how would it be unraveled but like
the biggest fight that I would have I've
got an agent he's in New York and the
biggest fight we'd have for years was
like what what like give me something
what's your this thing happened what's
your opinion on it's oh well I can see
this side and I can see this side so
it's like it's not well you know it's
interesting because like maybe there's a
place for that like nobody like the
vitriol is just
that's so 2022 like nobody like it's
just awful like I think it's interesting
like as as the whole world knows Donald
Trump was arraigned on Tuesday and that
was my book launch day and I was like I
can't believe that I'm just losing like
my entire like he's screwing me again
it's like I can't believe I'm losing all
like my media like I have any attention
like everybody's attention and it turned
out like I went I was on social media
all day because I was like commenting on
people commenting on my stuff I saw very
very little of anybody posting about it
or talking about it people are just sick
of it they're sick of the BS and the
nonsense and the anger and the hate and
they're just they're done they're over
it so there's an interesting thing to
think about like what if you were
somebody who actually
did both sides right like I can see both
sides I'm going to talk to this person
for 20 minutes about this side of it I'm
gonna talk to this person for 20 minutes
about that side of it and then I'm gonna
talk right like like there is a way for
you to carve the space that's yours
where people who are all in the middle
who are like I can see both sides but
I'm being so pressured to take a side
that I'm just stepping out of the
process completely yeah I mean I think
it connects back to your other advice
about relatability and vulnerability and
like hey this is how I how I see it I I
struggle with like how to inject the
belief into I don't follow Trends enough
and should and like how do I inject so
Donald Trump gets arraigned
people are like losing our minds on both
sides great how do I inject like how do
I be the Lighthouse of Hope in like in
all the darkness what do I say what do I
share if I were you I would I would say
like that there's stuff that's happening
in the world right now
it is not affecting your business
whatsoever what's affecting your
business is you being distracted by it
but how do we not be distracted by the
circus that's happening around us and
actually focus on what matters what are
you doing today to move your business
forward
well I know but like that doesn't that's
that's that's not the advice I would
give to
clients that doesn't really pop right
like how could I go in
how could I get in on the biggest
Twitter conversation for example and
just spread help and I'll take like as
long as it's a positive message like
Elon Musk put out the the record what
would you recommend to have in the
Twitter algorithm
you posted as like a poll like q a what
should I yeah what should the algorithm
prioritize and I'd say I'd love to see
an optimism uh filter or like it it will
boost posts that lead to Hope and
optimism and positivity right yeah but
here's the thing like you know Ashton
Kutcher had that whole like a plus news
like there's the good news network there
was Kid President like there's a lot of
optimism
you know optimism feeds or optimism
accounts that get a ton of great great
uh traction
so maybe it is that you're not far
enough on the optimism Spectrum right
yeah I mean optimism doesn't doesn't
sell as well as negativity but uh right
but you don't need to sell to 35 million
you need to sell to the right 3.5
million sure and I think the distraction
of how do I get the biggest numbers if
it bleeds it leads is stopping you from
being who you are for the people who
need you most fair I mean we don't put
anything negative out that's always been
the stopping point you know
there's nothing on the channel on the
content go back through 14 years of
content and there's never like here's
the stupidest things that this person
said which is right limited growth I
guess but also attracted the right
people in want the the optimism you
don't want the wrong ones
right but but leaning more I'm not far
enough into optimism I've never been
told that so that's a great uh that's
worth some meditation on to see where
that leads I mean if what you're saying
is like the people whose channels grow
are the ones who are outsized right they
are like
consistently
content that is like in your face and
taking a stance
you never said it had to be negative
nothing about garyvee is negative right
Tony is not negative Mel's not negative
they're all about Hope and optimism
yeah
no fair enough
so it may be that you need to just lean
further into it I'm a firm believer that
the that that all of the doors to the
kingdom the keys to the gates of the
kingdom are locked from the inside and
somebody in there has to open the door
and let you in
someone's got to walk you in you can't
just like climb over the gate and be
like I'm here everybody pay attention to
me now like that just doesn't you have
to be anointed right you have to be
anointed in some way
so you have this
you know bucket full of anointers
sitting next to you but
utilizing you spend a lot of time
creating content and you can piddle away
creating content here and creating
content there and nicking around the
edges but if you're not pulling the big
lever
like you have you rattled off five
people off the top of your head who
could take their giant Spotlight and
focus it on you for five minutes and you
would get a ton of attention
and you're not asking them
like are you waiting to make a perfect
content that have just enough content to
have just the right content
I think your content's pretty damn good
right like you have 3.5 million people
who agree with me yeah what are you
waiting for I don't know I'm wait what
am I waiting for I'm waiting for I'm
none of it feels big enough I guess I
don't know like share this video hey I
could share ask them share this video
just deal with Laura you know uh or or
some other video on the channel
I mean I'm looking at your numbers you
go what half a million people a year
yeah
and how many like what's the average
what's the average
uh uh YouTube subscription or subscriber
uh the average YouTube account how many
subscribers do they have three yeah I
mean yeah most people never I mean
videos
right like what percentage of YouTube
accounts would thaw off an arm
to have half a million subscribers
period hopefully not that many but I'm
sure there are lots so I'm just saying
like you have great content it's not the
content thing I think you are in your
own way for sure oh yeah yeah this is
all about me for sure yeah yeah so okay
everything feels too small what I asked
for feels too small what do you see them
doing with each other that you're like
wow that's a big thing I should get in
on that
oh
like vcon or whatever the like things
are that these people are doing
that's a great question
um
sure they'll still mean they'll be on
each other's shows around book promo
time whatever fine they'll speak on each
other's stages at different events fine
you know like vcon is great and he'll
have guest speakers come on
um
what else are they doing I mean some of
them have launched some businesses
together or some projects together
I don't know I mean it's worth a deeper
dive
it's worth a d for dive because I would
tell you
so I mean I'm older than you I'm going
to age myself here when I went to school
there we got textbooks right like we I
did a textbooks and there was all the
kids got a textbook and the teacher had
the teacher's Edition do you remember
teachers editions or am I like two yeah
yeah yeah the teacher's Edition like it
had all the math problems but it also
had teachers Edition had the math
problems with all the answers written
into it right like the teacher's Edition
exists you have the teacher's Edition
you can see what they're all doing
because they post about it all over
social media all the time you know what
the business models are you know where
they're making their money you know how
they're working together you know how
they're gassing each other up you know
how it all works you're subscribed to
all the newsletters like you could go
back and you could say let me look at
the all of the emails that Gary has sent
me or Tony has sent me before vcon or
you know greatness of women or like
whatever the things are and you can
actually in reverse order deconstruct
their entire Playbook like it's
newsletter newsletter newsletter pitch
pitch pitch sell newsletter newsletter I
don't know like what is the Kate of how
they sell to their people how do they
show up online who do they partner with
who do they tag like who sponsors them
you could you you could create in
reverse order the entire Playbook and be
like okay now I have it this is what I
do this is the small ass this is the
media mess this is the big ask
you have all of it and not only do you
have all of it they all know you so well
they trust it down with you over coffee
and just tell it to you
so you know you you have all the ability
to create whatever it is that you want
to create as the app that you want to
ask for them and they were dying to say
yes because you've helped them for so
many years well I feel very
uncomfortable right now which means it's
a good time
that's why we do this so the book is
called Wonder hell everybody or link it
up in the description down below Laura
we've got what two minutes left what
what um final message about Wonder Hill
do you want to lead people with well I
would leave this with everyone but I
would also leave it with you Evan which
is that Wonder hell only shows it's a
cell itself the people who are worthy of
it so if you were not made for more if
you were not capable of more you
wouldn't see that potential out there
and you wouldn't feel the burden of it
so uh exquisitely
so welcome to wonder hell
congratulations we're all here together
go support this amazing woman check out
the book when the hell first link in the
description below thank you Laura
appreciate your time your energy and
telling me why I suck to see garyvee's
life coach tell me why I suck check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there so everybody's got to
go they even have strategies in doing
this in action but the one thing I
discovered is hear people want to I'm
gonna make this up triple their business
let's say